poco distanciamiento social y unas
mascarillas que brillan por su ausencia
donald trump está en florida
el presidente sostiene 12 eventos este
viernes en este discurso al estado en la
carrera por la casa blanca con un
mensaje que no cambia y le ha entregado
el control a los socialistas marxistas y
a los neumáticos de la izquierda si él
gana a la izquierda radical va a
gobernar este país y son adictos al
poder
el mandatario también se dirigió en
florida a votantes de la tercera edad
sobre el sector que le ha ido restando
su apoyo en esta campaña por el manejo
de la pandemia sus votos se están yendo
hacia su rival joe biden que sostiene
este viernes eventos en michigan y
georgia otros dos estados pendulares es
decir estados que no siempre votan por
el mismo partido aquí el candidato
demócrata centró su discurso en los
intentos de trump de desmantelar el
obamacare
pero el mal manejo de la pandemia no es
suficiente para trump además de eso
también les quiere arrebatar su sistema
sanitario está todavía determinado a
hacerlo en medio de esta pandemia
desprenderme este viernes se conoció que
precisamente el ex presidente barack
obama estar acompañando a bailén la
próxima semana en un acto en filadelfia
que mientras tanto el país espera saber
aún si habrá un debate final antes de
las elecciones del 3 de noviembre de
momento va a ir en consiguió una pequeña
victoria de anoche no que se refiere a
las audiencias de televisión su evento
en la cadena ibis y fue más visto que el
de trump en bici